هذه البطاريات المثبته جزئيا على شاحنه
قذره على تغيير اتجاه اطلاق اربعه صواريخ
متتاليه بمدى 160 كيلو متر هذا هو نظام
باتريوت الامريكي للدفاع الجوي
بعد الولايات المتحده والمانيا تخططها
لندن لارسال جزء من رسالتها الامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا
للمساعدات الامريكيه والالمانيه وليس نظام
باكمله يؤكد رئيس وزراء هولندا لكن الرئيس
الاوكرانيه حاول الضغط للحصول على
البطاريه كامله
الهولنديين هذا يعني ان لدينا ثلاث
بطاريات باتريات مضمونه لكن هذه ليست سوى
البدايه
استهدافي مدينه نيبرو باعنا في الضربات
الجويه منذ بدء الغزو الروسي منظومه
باتريات المجهزه بردار عالي الدقه قديره
على اعتراض الصواريخ على مسافه تزيد عن
100 كلم لكن استخدامها يجب تدريب 90 جنديا
على هذا الجهاز المعقد وصل جنود من القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الى هنا
على الدفاع الجوي والذي سيركز على استخدام
وصيانه نظام باتريوت المضاد للطائرات
تتمكن من اعتراض الصواريخ التي تطلق على
بنيتها التحتيه ومنع روسيا من تحقيق
التفوق الجوي خاصه بالقرب من خط المواجهه